when opponents i have never played
testosterone from denmark i think the
mountain
is increasing so let's see what we get
yes i'm
watching what we get b6
at that point i think it's unusual
actually or i mean i could
play four now i don't know if  it's
good but
do 4
that's
ok that's funny of course i
thought he opens or does it
build the double that's now in the position
which is simply a reference advantage
i have the space advantage here
&
black doesn't have no play either i
can now play the parts here very comfortably
so just be careful that we don't let
some stupid blockade where
you still get in counterplay
because it's probably not
so important that which move you make
here first
and I'm just knight trumps
h4  the one idea tom has four jumpers
ii 4 well but should still be okay
just know
there you can also think about it
if he really  I play ok he
then hits the four away
a little
bit panic to
the jumper to jumper he now has
jumper f4
namely had the pawn
is not too bad
so we have it rather and
attack
so now there is still the opportunity
straight to f60 then it's all here
i'd like to see at once if
he doesn't even make
use of the opportunity to
break through that should actually be
enough
so he took it gets spider now has
3 6
so now can just here  take
or see what wins because now
well do we live here then the lady or
springer h6 actions yes yes that was it
i think letting an opening of the accident
go is funny and
then there it is in principle
yes for knows very well that one
advantageous structure
black but some of them are already
high yes if he
could hide them on the queenside or something like that or
stay a bit in the middle
but that's how we got when we
played has never
done anything about it then it's such a sure-fire success
the position h6 of course also offers
me the calling point directly but it
's very uncomfortable
he then also has the problem that the
bishop can move to how much maximum
can exchange and he can break the
pin, whether it's on 47 or something like that
then it would be better for us seven to stand at the
moment than on b4,
that was good